a lot of you asking me whether I think
that college is necessary for success in
this world well my answer is it depends
okay it depends um uh first of all um
what are the pulls what are your
priorities and so on experimentation by
and large uh if you use College as an
opportunity to explore and you also
develop relationships and you get a
whole lot out of college that's better
than the Alternatives at the time then
it's the better path if on the other
hand you go into the real world and you
mess around with that and you're going
to learn a lot more and then you can
come back and you can do college later
it's a choice so you have to find out
what are your circumstances don't let
convention stand in the way right let
the exploration of what are your best
Alternatives at that time and then go
explore uh life is not a straight linear
Journey you know it is a it is a path
and so that experimentation just as long
as you know that you're moving forward
that's what you have to go after